et merci de me recevoir merci de m'avoir
invité
merci gisèle merci à vous d'être là et
d'accepter d'écouter ce que j'ai à vous
dire à ce miracle de l'algérie alors
j'ai une amie qui m'a dit surtout
surtout rappelé à ne dis pas que tu as
pas grandi en tunisie
je vous ai promis que je ne dirais pas
donc mcmurchie tous mais je ne voulais
pas dit je suis tombé comme ça c'est
line meaux lotfi matin de parents
tunisiens comme vous et par le hasard de
la vie ma destinée m'a amené à partir
vivre en france j'ai grandi en france
j'ai fait mes études en france s'est
passé mon adolescence en france et par
d'autres
hazard encore plus curieux je me suis
retrouvé à donner des cours de théâtre
dans les îles du pacifique et l'océan
indien
à tahiti en nouvelle calédonie la
réunion bref où j'ai passé 13 années
le parcours d'une vie un petit peu
comment dirais-je atypique
je suis cadre commercial je suis
formateur professionnel et je suis
professeur de théâtre comme je voulais
dit à aucun moment je n'avais imaginé
qu'un jour je puisse revenir vivre en
tunisie dans mon pays
le hasard a voulu que de mes voyages de
mes rencontres
j'ai développé un certain nombre d'idées
un certain nombre de projets et ces
projets montrent un jour à ramener dans
mon pays il ya presque cinq ans de cela
donc je suis venu avant la révolution
j'étais là pendant la révolution et j'ai
décidé de rester après la révolution
pour aider mon pays à se reconstruire
pour cela j'ai créé une association
cette association s'appelle vérité et
confiance et dans le cadre de cette
association
j'ai élaboré un certain nombre de
preuves certain nombre de projets là
aussi comme par exemple la mise en
culture du safran
le ca france à farhan pour ceux qui le
connaissent
mais ça fera bientôt je parle du vrai
est vrai les safrans le vrai safran pour
vous donner une idée ça coûte plus cher
que l'or un kilo de safran coûtent 72
mille dinars
alors j'ai décidé de lancer ce programme
de safran dans les régions pauvres et
dire aux agriculteurs
nous allons planter de l'or dans vos
régions dans le cadre associatif tous
les revenus de la culture du safran
retourne à l'ensemble de la communauté
nous sommes une association à but non
lucratif je pourrais faire du safran
tout seul je pourrais 1 10 45 hectares
dans mon village je fais de safran
ouardi et je me fais une bonne
conscience en faisant travailler les
gens et en donnant de bons salaires
non j'ai voulu le faire dans le cadre
associatif pour être dans une démarche
d'exemplarité
nous devons être exemplaires
je voudrais vraiment que vous attachez
de l'importance à ce mot être exemplaire
avant toute chose avant de poursuivre
j'aimerais comment dirais-je vous parler
de comment je vois les choses
comment je perçois les choses vouloir
créer vouloir entreprendre vouloir faire
quelque chose c'est bien mais la vraie
question que nous devons toujours tous
nous procès c'est pourquoi pourquoi
voulons-nous faire telle ou telle chose
quelle que soit cette chose à l'époque
où j'étais comme vous sur les bancs des
écoles des lycées des universités gèrent
ça avait été interpellé par mes
professeurs de philosophie et on m'avait
parlé d'aristote et on m'avait dit à
l'époque d'aristote aristote disait
d'ailleurs je doute donc je suis vous
connaissez tous la fameuse phrase de
descartes je pense donc je suis sauf que
des cartes
il ne s'est pas créé tout seul descartes
il a évolué il a grandi et puis il est
surtout monte sur les épaules des géants
qui l'ont précédé il a traduit à sa
façon la pensée d'aristote
je doute donc je suis et c'est par là
même que je doute que je prends
conscience que je suis écouté bien ce
que je vous dis cet auguste a à peu près
la même époque disait je me trompe
donc je suis et c'est par là même que je
me trompe que je prends conscience que
je suis ce à quoi des cartes avait dit
je pense donc je suis avec l'ère
industrielle
au début du dix neuvième siècle la
pensée c'était jeu produit donc je suis
il fallait être producteurs pour avoir
une identité une identité sociale avoir
une existence je produis je travaille je
suis un ouvrier les années 70-80 dans le
monde entier ça a été je consomme donc
je suis c'est parce que je consomme que
je prends conscience que j'existe de mon
identité sociale mais aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui je vais vous dire ce qu'elle
a pensé
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas que je produise
qui fait que j'existe ou que je pense
que je doute que je me trompe
aujourd'hui c'est parce que je suis
solidaire qui existent aujourd'hui je ne
peux pas existé tout seul dans mon petit
coin
quoi que je fasse quoi que entreprennent
je dois le partager avec le plus grand
nombre
et c'est parce que je suis solidaire que
j'existe en tant que citoyen voilà
comment j'ai inscrit ma démarche
le safran la culture du safran je
voulais dit je peux le faire tout seul
et gagner des millions non mon pays a
besoin qu'on l'aide
il ya dans ce pays des gens plus faibles
il ya dans ce pays des gens qui n'ont
pas la capacité
on ne peut pas les ignorer on les a
suffisamment ignoré alors quoi que je
décide d'entreprendre aujourd'hui je le
fais dans cette action commune de
solidarité je travaille pour moi et je
travaille pour mon pays je voudrais
vraiment que vous ayez conscience de
cela
autre chose que je voudrais vous dire
n'ayez pas la faiblesse de penser que
vous pouvez changer les choses
n'ayez plus la faiblesse de penser que
ayez la force de croire en vous et là je
vais m'adresser plus particulièrement
aux jeunes femmes que vous êtes
vos mères vos grands-mères vous arrière
arrière-grand-mère une génération en
génération ont permis à ce que la
tunisie soit une réalité physique
ce sont vos mères qui vous ont porté qui
ont porté la tunisie dans leur ventre
c'est vous qui portez les générations
futures en vous vous êtes la matrice de
toute l'humanité
vous êtes la matrice de la tunisie alors
là aussi ne laissez personne vous
réduire à quelques schémas on voit
quelques stéréotypes
ils n'ont pas idée de ce que vous pouvez
peut-être ils n'ont pas idée de ce que
vous pouvez faire à condition que vous
vous une idée précise de ce que vous
voulez faire aujourd'hui dans votre pays
pour vous même et pour votre pays je
voulais vous dire ça je voulais vous
dire ça pour que vous preniez réellement
conscience de l'importance que vous avez
à titre individuel et à titre collectif
crois que nous décidions d'être quoi que
nous décidions de devenir nous le ferons
que parce qu on sera ensemble réunit
solidaire
j'ai imaginé comme je voulais dire un
certain nombre de projets j'ai été
interpellé dans ma vie par des
préoccupations je dirais qu'ils la
plupart du temps passé au dessus de la
de la tête de la majorité des gens mais
qui moi m'interpeller personnellement je
ne sais pas pourquoi c'est ma nature
un jour je rencontre un responsable de
l'unesco il me dit c'est une véritable
hémorragie à travers toute la planète
les artisans parce qu'ils sont pauvres
quand ils arrêtent de travailler leurs
enfants ne reprennent pas leur travail
reprenne pas leur métier reprennent pas
leurs savoirs ils reprennent pas leur
patrimoine
bien sûr qu'ils voudraient vivre une vie
de misère alors à l'échelle de la
planète c'est une véritable hémorragie
des pans entiers de notre savoir
disparaît allez après année presque
vingt ans de ça et cette idée je l'avais
en tête mais partout à travers mes
voyages quand je rencontrais des
populations je voyais leurs traditions
je voyais leur coutume je voyais leur
artisanat
je voyais à quel point à quel point
c'était vivant et à quel point c'était
important nous sommes non pas le fruit
de la civilisation mais véritablement de
nos traditions de nos coutumes
ce sont elles qui nous construisent sont
elles qui font notre spécificité nous
appartenons à ce corps humain tout
entier qui s'appelle l'humanité mais
nous avons notre spécificité en tant que
tunisien ou en tant que tahitien ou en
tant que polonais alors j'ai imaginé
j ai imaginé un projet j'ai imaginé un
concept unique au monde
unique au monde d'ailleurs ce projet il
n'existe nulle part sur la planète et
pourtant le besoin est vital de le créer
et j'ai imaginé la maison du patrimoine
de l'humanité
j'ai imaginé un lieu
où tout le savoir-faire de l'humanité
toutes les techniques de fabrication
traditionnelle artisanale serait non
seulement répertoriés archives et filmé
mais dans un lieu qui serait un lieu
vivant un lieu de création un lieu
d'échangé un lieu de communication
autre chose je ne limite jamais ma
pensée ah mais c'est le besoin
je ne me dis pas tiens j'ai besoin de ça
donc j'agis en fonction
l'idée elle doit être la plus ouverte
possible une fois que je lai amorcé une
fois qu'elle est sortie de moi je dois
laisser mûrir suivre sa propre évolution
sa propre maturation sa propre
expérience et j'observe pendant un temps
et de l'accompagner tout à coup l'idée
elle nous revient et elle me revient
avec des choses auxquelles je n'avais
pas du tout du tout du tout imaginé ni
soupçonné et la maison du patrimoine de
l'humanité quand elle a mûri dans mon
esprit et que j'en ai fait la maquette
je crois qu'on peut projeter la maquette
de la maison du patrimoine de l'humanité
voilà voilà la maison du patrimoine de
l'humanité
un projet utopique je vais vous le dire
très clair comme ça vous n'aurez pas à
me le dire
c'est un projet utopique que ça veut
dire utopique
ça veut dire qu'il peut pas se réaliser
non un projet utopique c'est juste un
projet qui est un petit peu en avance
c'est une idée qui est prématurée les
gens n'ont pas encore conscience comme
le canal de suez comme la tour eiffel
etc etc
jusqu'à ce que ça devienne une réalité
tout ce que nous entreprenons prend
naissance dans un esprit est d'abord et
avant toute chose une idée avant d'être
un bâtiment avant d'être quoi que ce
soit d'autre
c'est une idée l'idée la voici cette
idée a été soumise au président de
l'unesco quand j'ai quitté le président
de l'unesco il m'a pris par l'épaule il
m'a dit monsieur béjaouis si vous
respectez votre cahier des charges ce
site sera inscrit au patrimoine de
l'unesco
alors quand j'ai imaginé un projet de
développement pour mon pays
j'ai dit voilà ce qu'il faut pour la
tunisie
je peux entreprendre des choses à titre
personnel on est venu me voir il m'a dit
monsieur béjaouis dubaï est intéressé
par votre projet on vous l'achèterez des
milliards on vous accueillerai comme un
prince
j'ai dit non ce projet c'est pour monter
jeu même vous dire mieux
je ne veux pas gagné un centime sur ce
projet je veux lui offrir à mon pays je
veux en faire don à mon pays parce que
ça sera une fondation
ça sera pas un parc d'attractions alors
qu'est ce que ça va être la tunisie vous
chacun et chacune d'entre vous vous
allez représenter quelque chose dans
toute l'humanité quand on parlera de la
tunisie on dira mais c'est le pays qui
préserve le patrimoine de l'humanité
parce qu'il peut y en avoir qu'un seul
il peut y avoir qu'un seul site comme
celui ci peut pas y avoir deux et la
tunisie va devenir la garante de la
mémoire de l'humanité et nous allons
filmer archiver toutes les techniques de
fabrication traditionnelle de toute la
planète ça prendra 30 40 50 ans ça n'a
pas d'importance pour l'archivage pour
la construction du bâtiment ça prendra à
peu près entre 8 et 10 ans mais ça
deviendra une réalité
alors là oui je peux imaginer le
développement futur de mon pays
soixante mille créations d'emplois toute
une région qui va sortir de terre
il va falloir conceptualiser de nouveaux
modèles d'hôtellerie d'accueil
ça sera visité par 30 35 40 50 millions
de touristes qui peut le dire puisque le
site sera unique et authentique
nous allons reconstituer les jardins
suspendus de babylone tels qu'ils
étaient à l'époque de la boucle de niort
dire mais si fou mais c'est incroyable
mais c'est impossible de réaliser un tel
projet
si on vous avait dit ne fait pas la
révolution parce que c'est impossible
suis sûr que vous n'auriez pas fait mais
comme personne vous avez dit que c'était
impossible
vous l'avez fait je suis ma nature je
suis mon instinct
mais vous savez d'où je tire ma force
d'où je tire ma certitude dans ma
sincérité je suis sincère dans ma
démarche
malgré toutes les difficultés
malgré tout les porte qui se ferme
derrière moi quand j'ai développé le
projet du safran je suis allé voir le
ministre de l'agriculture il n'a pas
voulu me recevoir
je suis allé voir le président la
république sont conseillés il a pris mon
aussi et m'a dit monsieur béjaouis le
safran il a jeté sur son bureau
je vous jure que c'est vrai le safran en
tunisie et sa ne marche ra jamais je
vais dire excusez moi pourquoi mais
parce que si ça marchait on l'aurait
déjà fait on vous aurait pas attendu
vous pensez bien
problème pas de problème je suis allé
voir les agriculteurs et je leur ai dit
messieurs les agriculteurs vous qui
crevaient de faim vous qui êtes dans la
misère voilà mon programme et on va le
faire ensemble
elle nous l'avons fait et nous avons
fait pousser du safran tunisie à sidi
bouzid has been auxquels s'ajouent mine
même au kram
c'est pas le problème les autres le
problème c'est moi qu'elle est ma force
quelle est ma motivation qu'il est ma
sincérité
quelle est ma valeur ajoutée alors bien
sûr je suis un tout petit peu plus âgés
que vous j'ai un peu plus d'expérience
j'ai un peu plus de vécu je peux mettre
en avant ma valeur ajoutée vous vous
êtes encore très jeune mais je voudrais
que vous y et ceci à l'esprit
quel est votre valeur ajoutée
pour vous même pour votre pays
un jour j'étais dans mon village
j'étais avec mes cousins et on a croisé
un autre de mes cousins qui faisait
paître ses chèvres et à côté de notre
cimetière et je vous jure que c'est vrai
tout ce que je vous dis est authentique
on a un petit arbre alors vous
connaissez certainement le fruit de sa
robe pour ceux qui connaissent pas si
une petite baie qui ressemble à une
petite pomme et les chèvres elles
adorent les arts alors comme les humains
alors il y avait des chèvres qui ont
mangé les arbres qui étaient par terre
au pied de l'arbre et puis on avait deux
qui sont montés dans l'arbre et elle
mangeait les arbres qui étaient dans les
branches je vous jure que c'est vrai et
alors là il ya mon cousin mabrouk et là
regardez mon autre cousin il lui a dit
ils masotta carlo c'est pas pour les
chèvres c'est pour les humains et mon
autre cousin il a regardé il lui a dit
quand mes chèvres allemange dussart
lourd elle me donne du bord les toi
quand tu manges 2 0 au stade
mais au delà de la boutade
posez vous la question véritablement
qu'est ce que nous donnons à notre pays
ce que vous êtes ce que vous êtes en
train de devenir ce que vous serez dans
les deux trois quatre cinq années à
venir les jeunes diplômés que vous serez
pour la plupart d'entre vous vous le
serez pas ce que votre pays aura investi
sur vous il aura investi sur vous ça un
coup dans le monde entier et chaque
étudiant a un coût il est de l'ordre à
peu près de 160 mille dinars
je parle pas des dépenses que vos
parents ont fait pour vous pour vous
nourrir voilà pour vous achetez vos
vêtements voilà non non non je parle de
ce que vous avez coûté à l'état tunisien
s'est pas sortie depuis des générations
de la prochaine et de bourguiba et de
ben ali de maso qui sait ce que vous
coûter à l'état tunisien à votre pays
c'est ce que votre pays a mis en terme
d'investissements d'école
d'infrastructures de professeurs de
soins etc pour faire de vous des garçons
et des filles qui un jour allait devenir
des producteurs dans votre pays et créer
de la richesse pour permettre que l'on
puisse éduquer d'autres jeunes derrière
vous pensez à cela et dites-vous
quelle est ma valeur ajoutée qu'est ce
que je peux apporter à mon pays parce
que si je pense à titre individuel je
peux m'en sortir
bien sûr on peut trouver toujours des
choses à faire qui sont profitables à
nous mêmes
mais est-ce que ça fera gagner
l'ensemble du pays n'ont par contre si
je raisonne en disant qu'est-ce que je
peux faire pour moi et pour mon pays
alors là je ferai réussir mon pays est
forcément j'aurais aussi les fruits de
cette réussite
je voudrais vraiment que vous ayez ceci
à l'esprit ce projet la maison du
patrimoine de l'humanité si on peut leur
mettre la maison du patrimoine de
l'humanité
encore une fois je voulais dire c'est un
projet qui va changer la face de la
tunisie voilà c'est des millions de
touristes
ça veut dire aussi que nous allons
devenir maîtres de notre destin c'est
nous qui allons fixer le prix parce que
nous aurons quelque chose d'unique à
vendre nous aurons un produit qui
n'existe nulle part ailleurs la mer le
soleil la plage elle existe partout dans
le monde mais la maison du patrimoine de
l'humanité elle n'existera qu'ici mais
c'est aussi une autre responsabilité je
dis bien une autre responsabilité c'est
que nous allons devenir les garants de
la mémoire de l'humanité
encore une fois on me projetant à
travers ce projet à un moment donné je
me suis rendu compte que ce projet
c'était plus le mien j'en étais que le
dépositaire cuit ou quoi au casse a
choisi mon cerveau mon esprit pour le
faire jaillir mais il ne m'appartient
plus mais c'est vrai que dans ma famille
quand je leur ai dit je me fous de dubaï
je me fous des émirats je me fous de
ceci de cela je veut l'offrir à mon pays
mon dimanche victimaire bull qu'est ce
que tu vas faire en tunisie
je ne sais pas mais il ya une chose dont
je suis sûr
c'est que maintenant que je suis là avec
vous je ne peut plus laisser tomber mon
pays ça ne m'est plus possible donc
j'irai avec vous je serai avec vous
jusqu'au bout de cette aventure
quoi qu'il arrive par contre par contre
je suis maître de mon destin
c'est moi qui ai les leviers de ma
destinée c'est moi qui suis maître de ma
propre destinée grâce à mes idées grâce
à mes projets je peux venir vous voir et
vous dire ce projet il appartient à la
tunisie il vous appartient
nous pouvons faire ce que nous décidons
d'en faire ce sont les idées qui font
avancer le monde pensait toujours ça les
idées qui font avancer qui dirige clic
ouvert l'humanité tout entière
l'amérique est en faillite aller
chercher le petit jeune là bas quel
petit jeune suis à bas qui travaillent
dans son garage
le pauvre là bas le petit gamin la barre
en sorte oui vas le chercher de lever ce
dont il a besoin
mais qu'est ce que tu veux faire dans
l'huile ce dont il a besoin
il s'appelle bill gates aujourd'hui vous
avez un projet vous allez voir la banque
j'ai un magnifique projet quelles sont
vos garanties c'est pas de garanties
c'est pas possible
par contre si tu as des garanties on se
foutra même de ton idée qu'est ce qu'il
veut faire vie il va inventer le papier
toilette réversible s'ils disent non
mais il a des garanties à cela des
garanties c'est bon là bas et je voulais
avoir un avenir
alors il faudra tout repenser vous ne
pouvez pas construire la tunisie de
demain votre propre édifice votre propre
maison sans avoir bâti défricher et
établi des fondations solides profonde
on ne construit rien sur rien et
aujourd'hui la tunisie ce n'est rien
quelle que soit l'idée quel que soit le
projet on m'a invité parce que à la une
reste dix secondes
on m'a invité parce que dans la fois la
dernière conférence j'avais un petit peu
mis les pieds dans le plat et j'avais
dit mais ils ne peuvent rien faire rêver
parce qu'il n'ya aucune structure qui
vous permettent de vous développer vous
allez voir des responsables politiques
ils comprennent rien à ce que vous êtes
en train de leur dire penser à ça je
vous remercie de votre attention